bonjour tout le monde
aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'utilitarisme j'ai choisi ce thème
parce qu'il est dans la continuité de la
précédente vidéo sur les piqûres et là
je me suis rendu compte que il y avait
beaucoup de choses que j'aurais pu
ajouter en fait sur le lien entre
épicurisme et qui tarissent mme dont je
me suis dit que c'était l'occasion de
faire une vidéo complémentaires sur
l'utilitarisme en lui même j'ai expliqué
dans la vidéo sur l'épicurisme
l'utilitarisme s'était développé un
petit peu dans la continuité de ce
mouvement philosophique militarisme et
qu'apparut disons principalement au
xviiie siècle avec jal a dit ban dame
mais en réalité on peut trouver des
traces sont les germes de son mouvement
dans des philosophies antérieur je pense
par exemple à tout le mouvement
empiriste qui s'est développée dès le
xviie siècle qui s'est prolongé au 18e
soufflant de quelqu'un comme david young
par exemple et dans l'empirisme on
trouve ce qui va c'est qu'il a fécondée
la pensée utilitariste alors qu'est ce
que c'est que l'empirisme déjà pour
commencer
moi empirisme paraître un peu un peu
trompeur ça n'a rien à voir avec la
notion d' empire ce n'est pas
l'impérialisme l'an pièce moi empirisme
ça vient du grec
mp raya et qui signifie le fait
d'éprouver le fait de ressentir les
fentes indre le mot ressentir au sens
littéral c'est à dire ce qui attend nos
sens notre sensorialité ce n'est pas le
fait de ressentir au sens purement
émotionnel donc l'empirisme c'est une
doctrine philosophique qui considère que
toute connaissance par de la sensation
autrement dit tout ce que nous savons
sur le monde nous le savons pas ce à un
moment donné nous l'avons ressenti
ressenti dans notre corps ressenti dans
notre chère c'est donc l'expérience qui
est première dans toute connaissance
selon les intéristes de mon expérience
là aussi doit être entendu dans un sens
plus large le sens courant sens courant
l'expérience us et c'est le vécu c'est
la pratique quand on dit avoir de
l'expérience dans un domaine signifie qu
on a qu'on a pratiqué pendant un certain
temps mais en philosophie l'expérience
c'est tout rapport sensoriel à un objet
quel qu'il soit donc par exemple si je
prends un verre
voilà le faire une pause en face de moi
je peux le décrire je peux en décrire
les caractéristiques parce que je le
vois donc déjà je peux indiquer sa forme
je peux indiquer sa couleur mais ce ver
je peux également le toucher et dans ce
cas là je pourrais je pourrait indiquer
s'il est plutôt dur ou plutôt non de la
même façon ce verges peu le claquer des
doigts pour voir s'il produit un son
dans ce cas là et bien j'aurai une
informations sensorielles
supplémentaires sur son revers et ainsi
de suite comme on dit l'expérience c'est
tout ce qui me permet de connaître un
objet par l'intermédiaire des naissances
et pour les empiristes de toute
connaissance démarre par l'expérience
démarre par le contact sensorielle
je ne vais pas je n'ai pas traité en
fait cette cette position philosophique
dans cette vidéo parce qu'on s'est pas
l'objet mais j'y reviendrai j'y
reviendrai dans une prochaine
c'était simplement pour indiquer que
l'utilitarisme prend acte de ce postulat
de l'entériner qui est que finalement
tout démarre du corps tout part du corps
et tous les concepts toutes les idées
toutes les pensées et si tous les
sentiments que nous pouvons former en ou
sont directement corrélés à la sensation
la sensation c'est ce qui est premier
dans le rapport à l'objet
une fois qu'on a compris que
l'utilitarisme démarré avec nous car ici
on peut maintenant aller un petit peu
plus loin le principe de l'utilitarisme
c'est de dire que l'homme poursuit
d'abord ce qui lui procure du plaisir
est là on retrouve on retrouve l'idée
l'idée maîtresse de l'épicurisme savoir
que l'homme est naturellement attirés
par ce qui lui fait du bien parce qu'ils
procurent des sensations agréables donc
il va rechercher poursuivre le plaisir
et l inverse il va où se défier se
détourner de tout ce qui est cause de
tout ce qui peut être cause de malheur
de souffrance et de douleur
en ce sens on pourrait dire que
l'utilitarisme est basé sur un réalisme
anthropologique est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que l'utilitarisme ne
cherche pas sur a6 cacher les yeux
devant la nature humaine chez les
utilitaristes on ne trouvera jamais
l'idée que l'homme est attiré par mes
biens ou la vertu
on peut me dire que pour eux ce serait
de l'hypocrisie et toute l'histoire de
la philosophie toute histoire des idées
ne serait qu'une illustration de cette
hypocrisie de ce mensonge des
philosophes elle même qui veulent se
persuader que l'homme est attiré par
autre chose que la jouissance du corps
mais en réalité non pour les
utilitaristes c'est ça qui motive
essentiellement l'action humaine mais
les équilibristes vont plus loin
c'est à dire que pour eux ce n'est pas
un mal
ce n'est pas un mal de poursuivre ce qui
est source de plaisir
s'il est tellement pas un mal que ces
mêmes en réalité la seule chose qui
vaille et on entend souvent les
philosophes dire que le but de
l'existence humaine c'est d'atteindre le
bonheur
la dernière vidéo en témoignent du sco
l'épicurisme qui est une doctrine de
l'antiquité avait déjà cette aspiration
accéder au bonheur
et c'était déjà l'aspiration des
stoïciens atteindre l'ataraxie c'est à
dire l'absence de trouble jeremy bentham
va donc considérer que but de
l'existence humaine
c'est la quête du bonheur mais pour lui
le bonheur se réduit se résume à la
jouissance physique si je voulais être
un petit peu plus subtil je dirais que
pour baltard il n'y a pas de distinction
à faire entre le plaisir du corps et le
plaisir de l'esprit
si vous préférez pour vous donner un
exemple à peu concrets que l'on trouve
du plaisir et du bonheur en plongeant
les doigts dans la confiture pour les
lécher ou qu'on trouve son bonheur dans
la lecture d'un poème pour bentham
finalement peu importe c'est une
distinction qui est sortie du cadre
théorique eux n'a plus aucune
répercussion le plaisir et le plaisir le
bonheur et le bonheur robben dames le
plaisir c'est le bonheur et le plaisir
ne se discute pas de ce point de vue là
il n'y a pas chez madame une hiérarchie
des plaisirs il n'y a pas une
distinction séparation entre ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des plaisirs nobles et
des plaisirs guînes à partir du moment
où l'individu éprouve du plaisir dans
une action il faut considérer que ce
plaisir se justifie de par son existence
même
on voit donc que l'utilitarisme et
quelque sorte basé sur un subjectivisme
c'est à dire le fait que tout se ramène
au sujet à l'individu on dit souvent des
goûts et des couleurs on ne discute pas
ça signifie que si j'ai une préférence
ou esthétique ou gustatives bien
personne ne pourra me convaincre que ma
préférence est fausse
si je dis que j'aime la viande rouge et
que quelqu'un me dit que j'ai tort je
continuerai à aimer la viande rouge
vous voyez ce que je veux dire le bout
et la sensibilité sont une affaire de
subjectivité
c'est à dire une affaire individuelle au
bantam c'était un problème ce n'est pas
un problème puisque après tout si tout
démarre avec le corps si nous démarre
avec l'expérience sensorielle
il faut bien admettre que chaque
individu soit le son propre baromètre le
baromètre de son plaisir de son bonheur
alors je n'ai pas développé un set cette
identification du plaisir au bonheur
chez dame
tout simplement parce que lui-même ne la
développe pas il explique en fait que le
mot bonheur n'est qu'une aiguille
abstraction un petit peu ronflante une
sorte d'intellectualisation et de
conceptualisations de quelque chose qui
en réalité est beaucoup plus basique et
primitif qui est le plaisir
maintenant que faire avec ça que faire
lorsqu'on a dit que le but de la vie
était la recherche du plaisir et que
chacun était finalement le propre le
propre décideurs de son plaisir
individuel bien jeremy bentham va
essayer de mettre en place un système
soit la fois philosophique mais aussi
politiques pour savoir comment faire
émerger une société heureuse
partons du principe que si le but de
l'existence individuelle c'est la
poursuite du bonheur individuel bien le
but de l'humanité c'est la recherche du
bonheur universel
alors comment poser les fondements de
cette société du bonheur universel
et bien simplement en rappelant quelques
principes
le système conçu par dan tan n'est pas
en réalité un système moral
pourquoi parce que pour lui étant donné
que seul le plaisir qu'à considérer
toute autre considération serait
superflu ce qu'on appelle la morale dans
nos d'un aux termes actuels
c'est un ensemble de règles que l'on
doit suivre pour se diriger vers ce
qu'on appellera bleus bien où la vertu
par exemple on dira qu'il est mal de
blesser quelqu'un ou de tuer quelqu'un
les mâles de voler il est mal d'abuser
de la faiblesse de quelqu'un et cet art
etc
et bien pour bentham cette idée là elle
n'a aucun sens elle n'a aucun sens parce
qu'en fait elle n'est qu'une émanation
de l'esprit une émanation de la pensée
mais qui n'a aucune prise avec la
réalité la réalité du monde et la
réalité de la nature humaine
c'est une abstraction qui ne sert qu'à
masquer qui ne sert qu'à travestir la
réalité de cette nature humaine est ce
que dit d'entâmes c'est que ce que nous
appelons bien ce que nous appelons vertu
au sens moral en berne
ce n'est que la forme déguisée de ce qui
constitue en réalité pour nous un
bonheur et du plaisir donc plutôt que de
se mentir avec la morale plutôt que de
se mentir avec des concepts comme le
concept de bien le concept de mal le
concept que de dignité
par exemple le concept de respect de ces
choses là plutôt que de faire croire que
l'homme serait finalement plus noble que
ce qui n'est en réalité et bien autant
partir de la réalité de notre main
autant partir de cette aspiration
véridique qui est la recherche du
plaisir pour construire une société
heureuse parce qu'après tout nous dit
madame dans une société où tout le monde
serait heureux on ne se poserait pas
question morale
en réalité la morale est d'abord conçu
comme un moyen d'atteindre le bonheur ce
qui est suggéré dans la morale c'est que
si chacun respecte les règles de la
morale tout le monde sera le cas le plus
grand nombre par exemple le fait de dire
qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y ait quelqu'un
c'est parce que ça produirait la
souffrance la souffrance de celui qui
serait tuer ainsi marc avec souffrance
la souffrance également de ses proches
qui perdent un être cher et on peut
s'apercevoir que pour toutes les règles
morales
à chaque fois il s'agit d'éviter il faut
france et que donc après tout la morale
ne serait que l'espèce de convention qui
ne reposerait sur rien de réel sur rien
de tangible mais qui aurait pour effet
qui aurait pour résultat de diminuer
autant que faire se peut la souffrance
de l'humanité
donc si la morale a pour but le bonheur
de l'humanité bien autant enlever tous
les intermédiaires et la morale est un
intermédiaire selon mme al thani qui
doit être écartée je me souviens avoir
lu un texte les bantams dans lequel il
écrivait que la notion même de dignité
était une absurdité montés sur des
échasses la notion d'unité
selon madame ne repose sur rien tout
simplement parce qu'on n'en trouve
aucune trace dans la matière on n'en
trouve aucune trace non plus dans
l'expérience est qu'à partir de là il
n'y a pas lieu de postuler l'existence
d'une telle mesure
il n'y a pas lieu de postuler sa
légitimité sa pertinence au matin de ce
qu'on appelle la dignité ce n'est rien
d'autre que l'effet produit dans notre
corps par ce que l'on considère comme
étant des atteintes à cette prétendue
dignité si vous voyez quelqu'un souffrir
en face de vous quelqu'un que l'on est
en train de massacrer physiquement vous
allez éprouvé une souffrance une
souffrance intérieure
cette france on peut l'associer au
phénomène d'empathie qui est un
phénomène que tu dis certains
scientifiques notamment certains
neurologue et qui explique que en
réalité l'empathie est une réaction
physiologique presque une action survie
puisque on ne peut pas supporter l'idée
de voir quelqu'un souffrir puisqu'on
sait très bien que cette souffrance
si elle nous arriver serait proprement
insupportable c'est donc un mécanisme de
défense qui qui fait que la violence
doit nous être fondamentalement
désagréable parce qu'elle est une menace
contre notre vie alors bentham n'avait
peut-être pas connaissance en fait de
celle de ses interprétations
scientifique mais en tout cas il avait
vu juste dans le fait que on peut
expliquer d'un point de vue
physiologique des choses qui jusqu'àlors
ne pouvait être expliqué qu'à partir du
concept et le concept et des dignités
humaines a longtemps été considéré comme
une sorte de deux postulats moral mais
sans qu'il y ait de fondements matériels
et expérimentale à ce concept
c'est ça que en fait à pointer bantam à
une époque où les concepts notamment de
la théologie aussi de la philosophie y
est et de la morale étaient considérés
comme des évidences qu'on ne remettait
pas en cause
bentham a décidé de dire ces concepts là
sur lesquelles l'humanité fonctionne
depuis des siècles et des siècles on va
montrer qu'il ne repose sur rien on va
partir du principe que ce que recherche
l'homme cedh dial bonheur mais que ce
bonheur l'art n'est pas une abstraction
mais une réalité corporelle une réalité
sensorielle et physique et on va donc
prendre un raccourci on va arrêter de
prendre des tours on va arrêter de
prendre des chemins tortueux et signe
pour nous conduire à quelque chose qu'on
ose à peine s'ils demandent nommé et on
va aller droit au but
on va aller droit à l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'atteindre le bonheur
et le bonheur c'est un maximum de
jouissance physique
partant de cette conception
on appellera bonheur la somme de toutes
les licences physique et le but de
l'existence humaine
c'était prouver un maximum de jouissance
la devise de l'utilitarisme c'est le
plus grand bonheur pour le plus grand
nombre
alors vous voyez quand même que cette
devise montre bien que l'utilitarisme
n'est pas à proprement parler un
individualisme puisque un individualisme
conséquent devrait dire le plus grand
bonheur mais chacun pour soi là il
s'agit de dire le plus grand bonheur
pour le plus grand autrement dit il
il incombe à chaque individu de
travailler non seulement à son propre
bonheur et ce qu'il fait partie de
l'humanité mais aussi au bonheur de son
prochain au bonheur des autres puisque
peu importe qu'ils éprouvent du plaisir
peu importe qui est heureux à partir du
moment où il ya du plaisir
à partir du moment où il y à du bonheur
voilà pourquoi l'individu n'a finalement
pas un si grand statut dans la
philosophie utilitariste puisque
l'individu envoie un autre et qu'après
tout du moment que quelqu'un est heureux
on se fiche de savoir qui est heureux et
ça peut être aussi bien soin que les
autres même si évidemment d'un homme
reconnaît qu' on travaille d'abord à
notre bonheur individuel mais dans une
perspective utilitariste globale
c'est-à-dire collective voire politique
ce qui compte c'est le plus grand
bonheur du plus grand nombre
c'est à dire un maximum de plaisir soit
éprouvé
et donc ce que certains appelleraient
une sacralisation du plaisir lors on
peut le dire même si le mot de
sacralisation et déjà eu envie wallon
puisque s'il ya du sacré et du profane
et dame refuse purement et simplement
cette distinction entre sacré et profane
on a vu tout à l'heure avec le concept
de dignité ces concepts prétendument
sacré ne repose sur rien à partir de là
ils n'ont pas de validité dans le dans
le système utilitariste donc le plus
grand bonheur pour le plus grand nombre
ça signifie qu'il faut rechercher un
maximum de bonheur au niveau individuel
et multipliez ce bonheur individuel par
le nombre d'individus qui existe sur
terre
d'individus qui existe sur terre ça
tient compte également des animaux
puisque si on admet que les animaux
éprouve des sensations
il n'y a aucune raison que les animaux
soient écartés du processus d'accès au
bonheur qui est visé par l'utilitarisme
c'est pour ça qu'un penseur contemporain
comme peter singer philosophe australien
s'inspire énormément de de la pensée
qu'il t'a rist et de jarinje bentham en
disant que tous ces petits et
susceptibles d'éprouver du plaisir ou la
souffrance doit être pris en compte dans
un système politico philosophique qui
aurait pour objectif le plus grand
bonheur pour le plus grand nombre le
plus grand bonheur pour le plus gros
boum ça signifie que tout ce qui est
susceptible d'être heureux doit être
incorporé dans l'équation
le plus grand bonheur du plus grand
nombre aux eaux voit ici quelque chose
qui nous fait penser à une
mathématisation de la philosophie on est
sur des critères quantitatifs
vous avez remarqué qu' à aucun moment
band amnésie qui est bon ce qui est
mauvais subtil source de plaisir et ce
qui ne l'est pas puisqu'il laisse
l'individu a à ses propres préférences
mais le plus grand bonheur du plus grand
nombre
ça signifie bien qu'on est dans la
recherche de la quantité la quantité de
plaisir
on va donc être dans une arithmétique du
plaisir et dans une arithmétique moral
et ça c'est une idée qui souvent est
assez bien comprises lorsqu'elle est
énoncé de manière abstraite comme jeanne
le faire mais qui va soulever quelques
difficultés à partir du moment où on va
prendre en considération ses
répercussions pratique alors quelques
exemples pratiques de cette prescription
utilitariste on va prendre une situation
on va prendre le cas d'un homme qui
serait disons un arrivant dans un dans
un village dans une communauté c'est un
étranger en fait qui qui entre dans une
communauté et supposons que tous les
membres de la communauté soit d'accord
pour tuer cet individu cet étranger qui
n'a rien à faire ici
imaginons que il décide de mettre leurs
leurs dessins à exécution et qui se
ruent sur lui et et le tue physiquement
dans ce cas là qu'est ce qui se sera
passé
eh bien on aura eu un individu qui se
sera fait tuer sous les coups multiples
d'autres individus qui aura souffert
jusqu'à mourir bien cette souffrance on
peut imaginer qu'elle a dû être assez
considérable la seule chose c'est
qu'elle n'a été prouvé que par un seul
individu
celui précisément qui s'était tué
maintenant imaginons que cette
communauté des villageois soit au nombre
de 200 300 500 et que même si tous ne
participent pas de manière directe à sa
mort à sa mise à mort physique et bien
au moins il y assister il avec une
certaine jubilation dans ce cas là
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé
eh bien on a une communauté d'environ
500 personnes qui aura éprouvé du
plaisir dans le spectacle de la mort
d'autrui et si on multiplie
chacune de ces petites jubilation par
nombre de villageois
eh bien on va obtenir un indicateur de
bonne heure qui sera très largement
supérieur à la souffrance pour éprouver
celui qui s'était tué dans ce cas là
qu'est ce qu'on a
eh bien on a un acte que la morale
qualifierait sans aucune ambiguïté de
mal la morale ne dirai par exemple que
dans ce cas précis les villageois ont ni
la dignité de la personne humaine qui
l'a massacrée et que donc on a affaire
un acte purement et simplement immoral
autrement dit la morale ne pourra pas
justifiée à aucun moment la mise à mort
de cet individu
c'est une question de principe c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
s'est discute maintenant
et ce serait le point de vue des
utilitariste et bien il faut imaginer
que l'utilitarisme c'est quelqu'un qui
arrive
disons à la fin de la bataille et qui
prend un petit carnet sur lequel va
noter le taux de souffrance ce qui a été
produit dans ce lieu est le taux de
plaisir qui a été produit sur scène - et
donc il va procéder à une petite analyse
un petit calcul et à la fin de son
calcul
il va statuer que cet acte était bon
parce qu'il a produit plus de plaisir
que de souffrances en d'autres termes
peu importe ce que dit la morale sur le
bien ou le mal peut représente telle ou
telle action
peu importe que ce soit jugée bien ou
mal la question c'est de savoir est-ce
que ça a produit plus de plaisir où plus
de souffrance si la réponse qui sait ça
a produit puis des plaisirs et bien il
faut admettre que cet acte était bon
s'il a produit plus de souffrance il
faut admettre que cet acte était mauvais
point c'est tout c'est terminé ça
s'arrête là il n'y a aucune autre forme
de légitimation
il n'y a aucune autre forme de
justification l'anact que ce simple
calcul qui consiste à déterminer
c'est un acte a été plus bénéfique ou
plus maléfique
donc on récapitule comme ça je vous
laisse un peu reprendre vos esprits les
utilitaristes partent du principe que
tout démarre avec le corps et que de
manière fondamentale et clinique tive
tout rapport avec le monde n'est qu'un
rapport recense oriane partant de ce
principe on ajoute le fait que l'homme
est attiré par ce qui le rend heureux et
que c'est une très bonne chose puisque
le bonheur doit constituer le but la
finalité de l'humanité bentham ne prend
pas vraiment la peine les justifier ce
postulat tout simplement parce que pour
lui ce postulat se justifie par lui même
et d'eux mêmes c'est à dire qu'il suffit
d'observer les hommes pour se rendre
compte qu'ils poursuivent le plaisir qui
poursuivent la jouissance et il fuit la
france dans ce cas là on part de la
réalité
ces scanneurs réalisme anthropologique
et on accepte
on essaie simplement de savoir comment
on peut faire pour favoriser cette quête
du bonheur
étant admis que ce qu'on appelle le
bonheur serait due en réalité au désir
et à la jouissance du corps eh bien on
va mettre en place un système système
législatif qui va consister à atteindre
le plus grand bonheur des plus grand
nombre autrement dit à favoriser à
maximiser la jouissance étant éprouvée
par l'ensemble des êtres sensibles
le reste n'est qu'une illustration
pratique de cette doctrine l'exemple
j'ai pris tout à l'heure on était une
illustration parmi d'autres pour en
prendre beaucoup d'autres par exemple
sont pose la question que pensent les
utilitaristes du vol le fait de voler
quelque chose à un utilitarisme
conséquent répondrait mais à part
incompris puisqu'on vient d'expliquer
qu'un acte n'est ni bon mauvais a priori
il est toujours de par ses conséquences
en terme de souffrance ou de bonheur
utilitarisme est ce qu'on appelle un
conséquentialiste conséquentialiste mais
c'est toute doctrine morale qui juge une
action à partir de ses conséquences et
non pas à partir des principes qui la
motive donc si on commence à demander
aux utilitariste de ceux qui pensent ou
tel ou tel acte nous aurons toujours la
même réponse qui sera ça dépend ça
dépend de quoi est belle ça dépend si
tel acte à tel moment dans tel contexte
précis a produit plus de bonheur où plus
de malheurs et lorsqu'on aura fait le
calcul on pourra dire a posteriori si
cet acte était bon ou mauvais point
c'est tout ce qui compte c'est tout ce
qui justifie la morale utilitariste
c'est tout ce qui justifie qu'on gilles
une action comme étant bonne ou mauvaise
c'est à dire la quantité de bonheur
qu'elle aura réussi à produire donc ce
qui est certain c'est que si on a une
culture
disons religieuse ou une culture morale
c'est assez marqué assez ancré en soit
on ne va pas s'intéresser plus avant à
l'utilitarisme on va dire ben c'est pas
pour moi
je refuse d'agir dans la pratique
quotidienne comme s'il n'y avait pas de
principe comme si réalité sacré comme si
finalement tout était justifiable
à partir du moment où on pouvait en en
éprouver du plaisir dans ce cas là on va
dire que le sadisme le fait d'aimer
faire souffrir les autres peut être
justifiée d'un point de vue qualitatif
puisque après tout si le sadi qui prouve
beaucoup de plaisir peut-être qu'il
arrivera à éprouver plus de plaisir que
sa victime ne prouve de souffrance et
puis peut-être d'ailleurs même qu'on
peut aller encore plus loin en disant
que ça il suffit que la victime ne soit
pas consciente ou qu'elle soit endormi
au moment où la cu pour que ça tact les
produits innovants souffrance et dans ce
cas là vu que le criminel et qu'on aura
peut-être une jouissance sont dans dans
ce crime
et dans ce cas là on va dire avec la
catégorie puisqu'il a produit la
jouissance du criminel peu voilà
purement et simplement considérer que
c'est une doctrine totalement folle
totalement folle sur le plan éthique
faut bien comprendre que pour belles
dames c'est c'est une remise en cause
fondamentale des trains signalétique et
si ça vous intéresse je vous invite
on n'a pas ravi pencher mais pour autant
ce n'est pas parce que la doctrine
utilitariste est évidemment très simple
que ça résout tous les problèmes parce
qu'en réalité cette doctrine certain
nombre de problèmes et ces problèmes-là
bentham les a lui-même identifié et en
fait pour lui le principal problème ce
n'est pas de savoir si on a retenu les
sensibilités morales ou religieuses de
chacun parce que ça on n'a guère vu peu
ils sont des intérêts s'est totalement
la question c'est de savoir mais comment
faire pour déterminer la quantité de
plaisir et la quantité de souffrances et
surtout comment faire pour savoir
laquelle gagne à la fin
parce qu' il n'existe pas de thermomètre
du plaisir ou de thermomètre de la
souffrance et que puisqu'on l'a vu tout
à l'heure
chacun est le propre baromètre de sa
souffrance même son plaisir
ça rend le problème d'autant plus
difficile il n'y a pas de critères
objectifs d'évaluation du bonheur donc
comment faire c'est là qu'est le
principal problème alors belles dames
résume son le résoudre son problème
simplement en disant que chacun possède
une rationalité et la rationalité qu'est
ce que s'est passé précisément là la
capacité à faire des calculs à faire des
comparaisons à faire des évaluations et
que chacun doit être le propre géomètre
de son plaisir et et de sa souffrance
là encore ils gagnent quelques exemples
il prend l'exemple de celui qui
s'enivrent le soir et qui finalement va
subir des effets négatifs de cette cette
ivresse
ça rejoint l'exemple que j'avais donnée
avec l'épicurisme ou si je prends du
plaisir à boire du vin j'éprouverais en
contrepartie de la souffrance au réveil
j'aurai un mal de crâne qui pourra
peut-être nous faire regretter le
plaisir que j'ai éprouvé la veille
beltone va reprendre cette idée on qu'on
appelle le calcul hédoniste hédoniste ça
vient du grec puisque ça ça désigne tout
ce qui concerne la sensation l'hédonisme
en fait c'est la recherche du plaisir
des sens et de philosophie hédoniste
c'est une philosophie qui se donne pour
objectif de maximiser d'optimiser les
réjouissances du corps donc le calcul
hédoniste c'est le procédé par lequel
chacun est amené à comparer par
anticipation la quantité de plaisir et
la quantité de déplaisir que produira
telle action donc sur l'exemple de
l'ivresse bentham va cochez la colonne
des plus en disant que l'ivresse est une
sensation avec les puits dans la colonne
des moins
il va même noté d'autres choses par
exemple on pourra dire le mal de crâne
le lendemain et puis également la
réputation qu'on traîne le fait de son
ombre est un bon alors on au xviiie
siècle
c'est être un petit peu libéré par
rapport à ça mais dans tous les cas le
fait d'avoir une réputation d'homme de
femme qui boit c'est quelque chose qui
peut être pénalisant sur le plan social
à partir de l'arbre ça doit être pris en
compte
finalement dans ce petit calcul
hédoniste donc on va le mettre dans la
colonne
et puis faudrait également penser à la
souffrance ce qu'on cause par le nos
proches qui passent justement être porté
par ce comportement par cette recherche
de l'ivresse et bien cette souffrance de
nos proches on va là encore la prendre
en compte la mettre dans la colonne des
moins et puis on peut également parler
du fait que à acheter de l'alcool c'est
c'est dépenser de l'argent de l'argent
qui finalement pour être placés dans des
choses dans des choses plus utiles à
notre bonheur personnel donc cette perte
d'argent était elle aussi à prendre en
compte la mettre dans la colonne de moi
au final on se retrouve avec un calcul
avec une balance balance des plaisirs et
des peines
un des plaisirs et et de la souffrance
qui va pencher tôt du côté des peines et
qui donc va nous indiquer que bien à
bien y regarder et tout bien considéré
ce plaisir n'en valait pas la peine ne
valait pas la peine pourquoi parce qu'il
a finalement produit puisque des
conséquences négatives en termes de
bonheur que des conséquences positives
à partir de là on va considérer que son
ombre et n'est pas une bonne idée
sans maugréer quelque chose qui doit
être écarté d'un point de vue et elite
ariste on vous voyez que on n'est pas
parti d'une conception morale a priori
sur l'ivresse on n'est pas parti par
exemple de l'idée que d'ivresse peut
traduire une faiblesse une incapacité à
surmonter la réalité un besoin d'évasion
qui traduit une inaptitude à la réalité
un manque une sorte de comportement
pathologique
on n'est pas parti de tout ça parce que
ça pour les ex guitariste ce sont les a
priori qui n'ont rien à faire dans le
compiler downeast qui est le seul
critère d'évaluation du bien fondé du
mal fondées d'inaction on est simplement
parti de l'idée que si cet axe au avait
produit plus de plaisir que de
souffrances
elle aurait été bonne mais que comme ce
n'est pas le cas c'est toujours le réel
qui statue en dernier lieu elle doit
être considérée comme mauvaise est là
vous aurez sans doute été interpellé par
le titre de la vidéo qui est
l'utilitarisme juif sans entrave
évidemment j'étais un petit peu
provocateur en choisissant ce titre
puisque je verse sans entraves j'ai fait
évidemment référence à un slogan de mai
68 mais ça se justifie puisque les
événements de mai 68 dans leur partie
estudiantine et est largement inspiré en
fait des principes de l'utilitarisme
basé sur la libéralisation des moeurs
puisque des moeurs conservatrice et
contraignantes ont constituerait un
obstacle à l'accès au bonheur bon
pourquoi
philosophie de mai 68 est elle aussi une
philosophie hédoniste et me disais que
j'étais un petit peu provocateur parce
que si on veut bien être un petit peu
plus subtil en réalité il y à des
entraves à la jouissance d'un
utilitarisme mais ces entraves ne sont
que logistique
elles ne sont que fonctionnel c'est à
dire que la seule entrave à un plaisir
c'est la quantité de souffrances mais ce
plaisir sera susceptible d'occasionner
auquel cas il peut ne pas en valoir la
peine mais c'est la seule entrave qui
est posée dans la recherche de la
puissance et 7,7 cette limite qui était
posée elle doit être prise en compte par
chacun tout simplement pour limiter la
quantité de souffrances inutiles qui
serait produite par méconnaissance ou
par an par précipitation
voyez l'idée que âgées quelque chose qui
me fait envie
je vais le consommer parce que ça va me
procurer du plaisir d'acorn à ce moment
là je ne pense pas aux répercussions
négatives qu'il peut y avoir
et donc je ne fais pas le travail que je
suis censé faire dans une perspective
qui guitariste qui est de procéder à ce
calcul des pays à des peines avant de
nous décider
mais hormis cette entrave purement
technique
en réalité il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
d'obstacle à la poursuite du plaisir et
à la poursuite de la jouissance
je terminerai cette vidéo en en essayant
de mettre le doigt sur quelque chose
vous avez remarqué que quand je fais une
vidéo de philosophie je choisi un thème
on ça peut être un auteur ça peut être
un mouvement ça peut être un concept aux
portes
mais dans tous les cas mes vidéos vous
arrive c'est une forme fragmentée
j'aimerais bien être en mesure de faire
une sortie des eaux
de dix paires vidéo de vidéo globale qui
intégrerait tout ce que j'ai à vous dire
mais c'est difficile qu'on ne pas dire
qu'on va dire impossible
mais si on observe un petit peu le
mouvement qui est décrit au fil de
l'histoire au fil de l'évolution humaine
on s'aperçoit que certains principes qui
gouverner la pensée dans l'antiquité ont
été progressivement rejeter
progressivement écartés et s'adonnent à
ces bonnes indications sur l'évolution
de nos sociétés
on a vu que chez les grecs la vieille
notion fondamentale qui était la notion
de modération on sonde équilibre
tempérance on trouve également ce mot
dans les textes de philosophie et
progressivement cette idée de modération
a été considérée comme quelque chose qui
ne reposait sur rien de réel sur rien de
concret rien de matériel rien qu'on ne
pouvait nous sommes donc on a eu une
évolution vers une forme de matérialisme
de la pensée qui allait vers eux
toujours moins de l'abstraction toujours
moins de spiritualité dans
l'interprétation du monde et dans la
construction dont des théories
philosophiques et on s'aperçoit que
malgré malgré cette cette entreprise de
démolition de la sphère spirituelle la
spiritualité en réalité n'a pas disparu
on pourrait dire que la spiritualité a
investi le champ matérialiste au sens où
les les principes de ce matérialisme
c'est à dire dont on considérer que le
corps est que ce qui a une existence
matérielle ses principaux ronds ont fini
par revêtir une forme quasi religieuse
ce que j'appelle le religieux c'est
précisément la distinction entre sacré
et le profane
alors ces mots de sacré et de profane
ils ne sont pas employées directement
par les représentants de ce matérialisme
mais en même temps ce qu'on pourrait
s'attendre à ce qu'ils en ces termes
puisque précisément pour eux la
spiritualité n'a pas sa place alors
meilleur moyen en fait de répondre à la
question c'est d'observer la manière
dont ils se positionnent par rapport au
rapport à ses principes matérialiste et
de se demander si pour eux ces principes
là sont intangibles
ces principes là sont finalement des
dogmes c'est à dire des choses en
lesquelles on adhère et on ne remettra
en cause sous aucun prétexte et puisque
les remettre en cause ce serait
enfreindre la raison des choses comme ça
est ce que le conseil
deux raisons à ce que le concept de
matières sont des concepts sacré banc
et si la réponse est oui si la réponse
est oui dans la manière dont ces
concepts sont sont défendu avec ardeur
on pourra considérer que le matérialisme
peut aussi revêtir une forme spirituelle
voire e religieuse et si à linverse on
observe ces concepts ses principes du
matérialisme peuvent être discutés
peuvent être contestées peuvent être
contredit sur le plan d'eau de
l'argumentation philosophique dans ce
cas là on pourra considérer que ce
matérialisme n'est pas n'a pas une forme
religieuse et qui peut être débattu en
tant que position philosophique
voilà j'en ai envie de conclure sur
cette interrogation et en espérant que
cette vidéo vous aura intéressé je vous
rappelle que vous avez le devoir lui
devoir absolu de vous abonner à ma
nouvelle chaîne le précepteur le lien
dans la description et je précise que
vous avez le devoir tout aussi absolu de
partager vos réactions dans les
commentaires et je vous espérait que
entre commentateurs vous saurez vous
saurez vous répondre les uns aux autres
vous saurez vous considérez les uns des
autres et peut-être faire émerger des
pistes de réflexion qui me feront qu ils
feront avancer et qu'ils nous donneront
des idées de nouvelles vidéos
je vous remercie pour votre attention je
vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]